Mushu parody man I would never have
found out that my sister is an
accomplice
without this list the boiler make them
perfect it's a detailed surveillance
document it's extremely likely that this
is authentic yes it's dangerous but
someone should tell the world what's
going on there Istanbul
these men are Wiggins limbs from China
back home they could be imprisoned for
the simple act of praying I quickly come
to realize that each one of them has a
story of loss the fascist Chinese
government wants to eliminate the weaker
people of shinjang the entire population
of Xinjiang right in front of the eyes
of the world we asked them to raise
their hands if they have family members
who've been imprisoned in China's
Xinjiang province where most we Gers
live across chin Jiang there are dozens
of camps holding up to a million we gus'
let's take a closer look at one of them
this is a region camp next to a prison
we identified watchtowers and high walls
there are countless camps like this one
the Chinese government claims they are
voluntary vocational training centers
designed to fight we extremism but we
received a document which shows that
china is targeting we guess based on
their identity and religion it lists
hundreds of detainees and the reasons
for their detention
cause my posted weaker academic app to
way Leah you perceived it from a source
and took a huge risk sharing it with us
January 8th are you see with the phone
call like is its messenger call and he
said that stop doing this and we can
reach you wherever you are
yes it's dangerous but someone should
take the danger someone should speak up
shaman someone should tell the world
what's going on there the document
doesn't have any stamp or signature we
showed it to several experts who agreed
that it is almost certainly an official
text it contains an enormous amount of
extremely specific data from one very
small community in in Xinjiang and that
it would take an immense amount of
effort and access to publicly
unavailable data to fabricate a document
like this in this neighborhood in
Istanbul where many we gus' live we met
one woman whose sisters are mentioned on
the list
what's in these are takhtee new some
family members had been imprisoned but
it shocked her when she found out that
her younger sister was listed in the
document colon became bolder I was
really sad for days I couldn't sleep I
was really shocked and sad about her
arrest
China says it's fighting extremism but
Takhti says her younger sister wasn't
religious her only crime she had too
many children I heard that the
conditions in prison are unimaginably
bad they don't even have enough food to
eat she doesn't know if her relatives
have been released like countless are
the wiggers they have been caught up in
China's all-encompassing
anti-terrorism Drive and that report by
Naomi Conant from DWS investigative unit
and Naomi is here with me a very
disconcerning revelations this document
was leaked to DW news walk us through
some of the steps that you took to
verify the authenticity of this document
sure so we arrived we received some 140
pages in Chinese a PDF document with no
seal or stamp so the first thing we did
obviously was translate some of it to
figure out what this was actually about
then we showed it to several of the
leading experts on weaker history on
weaker politics all said it was most
likely authentic a lot of what is in
this list correlates with what we've
heard already the next step was to try
and find relatives because obviously we
couldn't travel to Qin Jung we couldn't
get hold of people there because it's
impossible to contact people that and
itself will put them in danger so we
managed to find some of the relatives I
talked to some with relatives of these
people on the list and then what we also
did is that we looked at several of the
camps that are mentioned in the list
that these people are sent to rehab that
so-called reeducation camps we managed
to verify them using governmental
Chinese governmental bids also satellite
images so we're pretty sure that we
verify two of the camps and most likely
located two other of the camps so we are
pretty sure that this is an authentic
document what do we learn about the fate
of the detainees from their sleep
document so we know that some of the
detainees have been released that
doesn't mean that they've been released
into freedom it means that they're still
heavily controlled monitored
some some of them probably can't move
around freely I mean there's a whole
network of surveillance in Xinjiang
they're surveillance cameras everywhere
other detainees have been sent to labor
camps those can be factories within the
villages where they're from they could
also be factories in other labor camps
and more worryingly we've also heard
that some people have been sent to
prison so they even if they have been
released from these so-called vocational
training camps they're I hope by no
means free at all these are very
frightening scenes that you described
have you been able to get an official
reaction from Chinese officials so we
actually managed to talk to the Chinese
foreign minister who is in Berlin on a
state visit last week and this is what
he said to us no one has seen any kind
of concentration camp in Xinjiang no one
has seen any persecution the only thing
to see was people of various ethnicities
in Xinjiang living together harmoniously
these facts demonstrate that the
so-called concentration camps the
so-called 1 million are 100% rumors they
are complete fake news figures fake news
and Iommi complete denial they're
complete denial but I mean that's not
surprising that's what the Chinese
authorities have been saying all along
they keep on stressing that these are
the occasional camps that people gave a
voluntarily so it's not surprising that
we didn't get a different kind of
response all right a DW must've reporter
Naomi Conrad thank you very much